you've changed your appearance the suit
is necessary
justifying a ridiculously elaborate
superhuman costume purchase
now it's time to get rid of my husband
merit aside we begin by dismantling
everything that protects him technically
skin protects him so are we peeling that
off this episode
guys shouldn't it be all hands on deck
with iris camilla and sing stuck in the
mirror verse
you said all of that dialogue with so
much conviction and didn't even come
close to cracking a smile
is danielle panabaker the greatest actor
ever i think daniel panamaker might be
the greatest actor ever
katie keeps our heavy coats in the back
closet i'll check on it you're
so good at this kind of stuff he says
she's good at this kind of stuff
as if following directions to retrieve a
code is something that sets her apart
from the normal instruction following
folk
and sure their relationship is
complicated or whatever but my point is
you're complimenting wrong
why are we meeting here i have a backlog
of cases i can't lose my csi job along
with everything else
barry was able to keep his job after
disappearing for six months at one point
pretty sure he's not gonna randomly lose
his job today because he's backed up on
a few cases
do csi's get tenure because that's the
only way any of this makes any sense
oh yeah this is a triangulation
cartograph
it's a treasure map that's a dramatic
way of saying plot convenience device
the center's a 42nd and darby but only
because that's where she's aiming the
immensely convenient swirly overlay
if she lifts her arm slightly you'll be
sent to the dunkin donuts instead which
honestly would make this show much more
interesting it turns out that is a
ginormous warehouse with five
subterranean levels which you can see
from the satellite imaging
somehow because bs tech is bs
look how casually he walks away here as
if he just watered plants rather than
set a fire to a room filled with
missiles and explosive
what a dilly dally doofus putting out
this fire with two little pat pats
eve has been trapped in another
dimension for the last six years a place
called the mirror verse
all this talk of the mirror verse just
reminds me that star trek did it better
also i'd give all the sins back if the
show gave us an evil spock or a
dominatrix and cura narese
i had the most brilliant minds in the
world study that
mirror verse but how carver is under the
impression no one can return from it
so how exactly did these brilliant minds
study it without traveling to it
your iris is long gone
considering how one of the show's
strengths is the diverse cast of
characters it's a little disappointing
that the main storyline really boils
down to barry having to save iris from
something a lot of the time
are those just random pillows strewn
about the benches what is this [ __ ]
restaurant
there was thermal energy coming from a
specific place i'm not sure where but
that has to be david
if you're trying to move the plot along
and that's all this show ever seems to
do then
yes it has to be david otherwise it
could be gerard who is on his way home
from the u's bookstore
i never meant to cause a stir i read eat
pray love and i took the prey part just
a little bit too seriously
reading we realized how much trouble you
went to
do you have a pen in this version of
earth checks are still a thing if i've
said it once i've said it a thousand
times anyone who owns a pen like this
deserves
100 sins okay fine
but my parents are safe and i can
finally go home
speaking of parents the two of you have
been out here for all the some time how
long do they think it takes for two
people to find a pen
so if anyone in the mirror verse can
just grab people and bring them in
whenever they want why is no one
grabbing carver
i mean i would want the badass trio of
ladies on my side but isn't carver the
main goal
this pose i need your help after all no
wonder central city has such a high
crime rate the police station is so
lacks they just let citizens wander
around until they find who they're
looking for
then again i've made so many mistakes in
my life maybe
maybe i'm the one who needs fixing
melodramatic skill
cause from where i'm standing you said
sitting wrong
what is taking so long reddit comments
about this season somehow make their way
into this episode
i don't get it why doesn't she just come
after you herself character whose name
i'm not even going to pretend i know
would be up to speed at tv since
mcculloch's security system can protect
us if that's the case why did carver
come to team flash for help
what do you think iris will say
when you tell her you traded another
person's life to save hers
phew good thing there's so much tension
in this moment that doesn't play out we
just
love dead ends of emotion like this
you're not here to rob the place
number one rule of the highly secret
black hole club wear the massive pin
on your lapel for all to see do you
understand what happens
if you kill carver this episode is 67
people convincing other people not to
kill carver
i'm sorry about this like this is the
slowest spray attack i've ever seen
how he doesn't even see this coming and
prevent it from happening by at the very
least slapping her hand away
is entirely beyond me also this face
oh come on no one sees this even though
there were people all over the lobby
just a second ago
this isn't about a paycheck ben affleck
shaming
eva's coming for you carver after
suffering through almost 27 minutes of
this boring build-up i have to say
i do not believe you
brian de palma's the flash is she frying
people at night you want to say
something truly hilarious
watch how this question is answered
braces aren't fashioned for fuel
yep gnash races to these two cowards
hiding by the elevator slides closer and
flips around dramatically to answer
their question you know rather than use
the comms they always have in their ears
nightmare fuel and so the heroes finally
decide to jump in and turn the tide but
not before standing back and watching
all the bodyguards be brutally murdered
no i mean why are you upset when there
are so many ways to kill a man
you know someone once told me to never
give up so if at first the mirror shards
don't succeed
that's okay pick up a gun and try again
am i encouraging correctly
well that was inspirational a true
example of determination
what are you doing here making this up
as i go doubling down on a line of
dialogue that wasn't interesting the
first time around
know that i am working with the ccpd to
try to find my husband's murder
and as for mcculloch technologies i will
be resuming my position as
ceo this works that's what joseph would
have wanted
and of course what joseph would have
wanted supersedes any legal
documentation that was already in place
since she's been dead for six
years the reason you beat
zoom godspeed thon is because speed
isn't what drives you
it's love i'm pretty sure it's speed so
as long as you stay true to yourself
you will always find a way to beat the
bad guys once again you're still going
to need your powers though
holy frack iris you can control this
place convenient cliffhangers
convene angers clivenians
the question is who are you
[Music]
tired
night in the city and a brave band of
heroes is ready to face fiendish
villains
to stop them messing with your day
guys shouldn't it be all hands on deck
with iris camilla and sing stuck in the
mirror verse that doesn't make sense
you knew iris was abducted that's what i
do
i drink and i know things it's so good
to meet you
alrighty then stand up straight when
you're talking me
[ __ ] the primetime [ __ ] good morning
angels
i live in two worlds one is a world of
books
i've been a resident of faulkner's yucna
patafa county
hunted the white whale aboard the pequod
fought alongside napoleon
sailed a raft with huck and jim